so you are saying marriage is two humans  promising each other to be together  forever yeah you don't have romantic  relationships on your planet of course  we do but we don't promise each other to  be together in the future oh yeah wait  why well we know that the connection to  each other is based on our current  energetical state and it is a law in the  universe that energy is always shifting  and moving so no one knows  so you guys don't have long-term  relationships sometimes we do when the  energy of both parties grows in the same  direction my last relationship lasted  for centuries and we just thought it  went  why does the alien sound like  Christopher Walken I don't know it was  the only thing I could think that entire  time